you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
millions of households to pay hundreds
of pounds more for their energy bills
but where does this leave the big energy
suppliers and the transition to greener
sources of fuel
the world's first wind farm co-op which
could provide a model for making green
energy at cheaper prices for consumers
and an oil production ship carrying up
to 2 million barrels of oil explodes off
the coast of nigeria
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
we start tonight with the impact of
today's big announcement on the energy
price cap on households and the uk's
ambitions to move towards a greener
energy supply while the regulator's
decision to raise the cap making bills
more expensive seems unavoidable given
surging gas prices some critics say that
unless the country's dependency on
fossil fuels is reduced people will
continue to suffer rising energy bills
in the future so let's remind ourselves
of the main announcement today well
ofgem has increased the energy price cap
by 693
pounds a year now that's a rise of 54
in the maximum amount an energy company
can charge an average customer to
1971 pounds now for customers on
pre-paid meters the price cap is rising
to
2017 pounds
well let's take a look at our data
dashboard now which shows us the uk's
current energy makeup and today you can
see there that 35.1 percent of our
energy is coming from gas we've got 3.1
percent coming from coal both of those
fossil fuels of course and we've got
here about 39 coming from renewables and
most of that figure is made up of wind
power
well our climate change correspondent
hannah thomas peter joins us now so
hannah where does the price cap rise and
the government's response to it as well
leave the oil and gas industry hannah
there had been calls for a windfall tax
on the industry but that didn't happen
well at the moment it leaves them making
lots of money in the uk uh you know
extracting oil and gas from the north
sea is uh very profitable
um and you know these big energy
producers have been are in general in
regular contact with the government they
will have been making the argument
that a windfall tax would perhaps
destabilize them when they are needed to
provide an essential service this huge
demand for gas in particular
they will have made the argument that
they've only just started recovering
from record losses during covid
and perhaps more importantly when it
comes to the broad strategy around net
zero and the transition to renewables
they will have been saying look if you
tax us now on our profits we are going
to start struggling to invest fully in
renewables and the transition to
renewables
as we had promised um and so uh you know
perhaps the government listened very
carefully uh to those arguments and and
made its calculations but it does remain
the case that the uk is a very good
place for oil and gas companies to do
business that is how it is regarded
there is a a generous tax environment we
have reported on sky news before that
many of the big companies operating in
the north sea in fact pay negative tax
over the last couple of years because of
generous allowances for capital
expenditure and decommissioning
rebates campaigners for that reason have
long claimed that these big companies
are are paid
to pollute and it is also the case that
these energy price rises that are making
these big oil and gas producers so much
money are also causing an awful lot of
pain now for ordinary consumers
okay hannah thank you for the moment
stay there will you because uh 22
million homes will be affected by this
increase in the energy price cap and
those on lower incomes will be the
hardest hit while helen smith has more
on what's driving this rise in the
energy price cap
your bills could be about to go up by on
average almost 700 pounds a year it's
because of a rise in the energy price
cap of 54
but what is the energy price cap and how
will it impact you well since 2019 ofgem
the energy regulator have been limiting
the amount that energy companies can
charge households for every unit of gas
and electricity it's so people aren't
really overcharged for normal things
like cooking food eating homes or
charging up your phones do you worry
that you're going to be in a position
where sometimes you'll have to be like i
can't put the heating on cause it's just
too much at the moment
well that's
what i do
you know
leave me coach on
but it's also to make sure that energy
companies aren't going out of pocket too
every six months offgem looks at how
expensive power has been to buy and then
adds on other operating taxes and costs
and that's how the energy price cap is
set one thing though the cap isn't the
maximum you could be charged for your
energy use if you use more you'll pay
more in essence it reflects a typical
energy use i'm on my own
so i've still got the same meeting as
everybody else
say it family
it's got money coming in i haven't
and the increase only affects customers
on variable gas and electricity tariffs
so why has the cap gone up the price
energy companies are paying for power
has gone up for a few reasons an
increase of demand over a very cold
winter an increase in demand from asia
and china and also to replace what was
supposed to be provided by renewable
energy sources over what's been a
particularly calm and mild summer
but the actual power is not the only
thing we're paying for we're also paying
to get that energy into homes and for
environmental and social costs as well
so will the price cap go down at all
well here's the bad news the cost of gas
that we're particularly reliant on isn't
expected to go down anytime soon the
next price cap review is in october and
unfortunately it's expected to go up
again
so hannah back to you and as we were
hearing there a huge financial hit then
for the general public so what do you
think that could mean uh for attitudes
towards the funding of a green
transition
well that is the thing that has been
worrying politicians and those in charge
of delivering
net zero because
the estimation is that it could be
around one and a half trillion pounds of
spending between at now and 2050. an
awful lot of that is going to have to
happen in the next 10 to 15 years
of course it will deliver huge savings
and a cleaner greener life but that's
also a lot of money the treasury hasn't
ruled out raising taxes to pay for
getting to net zero but can you imagine
doing that in the current environment
given all the costs that we're already
bearing or the general public is already
bearing it hasn't ruled out reducing
public spending in order to help with
net zero
that's something that they'll be
considering on an ongoing basis
and there are schemes available already
loans grant systems and so on support
for people to invest in going green
to switch from a gas boiler to buy an
electric car
and so on but it is just the case that
the government will not be able to cover
the out-of-pocket investment costs for
everybody in the uk and that people are
going to have to find the money and the
worry is that they won't be able to do
that there's already a growing group of
mps within the conservative party
campaigning and making quite a lot of
trouble for the government on just that
issue and there is today a warning uh
from the business and energy and
industrial strategy committee that the
government's decarbonization plan for
homes that's the switch from gas central
heating over to
electricity powered heat pumps is
nowhere near in the right place it needs
to be a massive campaign to support
people and encourage them to do so or
they warn the government's net zero
targets are in jeopardy
hannah thanks very much indeed
now an oil production ship capable of
carrying up to two million barrels of
oil has exploded off the coast of
nigeria the trinity spirit which can
process up to 22 000 barrels of oil per
day was situated near warri in southern
nigeria when it burst into flames
sky's john sparks has been following the
story
huge plumes of billowing black smoke
were seen rising from this production
facility located off the coast of delta
state in nigeria and the production
facility called trinity spirit is big
more than 330 meters long more than 50
meters wide and it was designed to pump
oil out of the seabed to store it and
then to offload it
there was an explosion here early in the
morning and there are reports that the
vessel has now sunk
there were 10 crew members on board but
we don't know at this stage if there are
any casualties
an industry source says the trinity
spirit had 50 000 barrels of oil on
board when the fire took hold although
it was not believed to be pumping oil
from the seabed at the time and if
that's correct it will come as something
of a relief no one wants a repeat of the
deep water horizon disaster in the gulf
of mexico when an explosion ruptured the
opening of the well or the well head
in that case four million barrels of
crude flowed into the sea
in nigeria i'm afraid that oil spills
are nothing new thousands of spills have
been documented in the oil-rich delta
region and they've caused widespread
environmental damage destroying the
area's mangroves and swamps and
depriving local residents of things like
clean water
confusion surrounds the company that
owns the trinity spirit it's called
sheba exploration and production media
reports say it had its oil license
revoked two years ago
but the company still seems to be
operating and in a statement the chief
executive pledged to investigate the
cause of the explosion
now for some of the day's other climate
news and as we've been hearing mps have
urged the government to set a clear date
for banning the sale of new gas boilers
the business energy and industrial
strategy committee says around 29
million homes in the uk need
retrofitting with low carbon heating
systems and other energy efficiency
measures the mps say that government
policies to cut emissions from homes are
nowhere near the scale needed to reach
net zero by 2050.
the new study has found that almost all
of the uk's forests and woodlands are at
risk due to damaging farming and
forestry practices the soil association
says 99 of plantation forests and 93 of
native woodland are not in good
ecological condition they say a move to
regenerative forestry is needed
increasing the number of tree species
and maximizing forests carbon storing
properties
every hospital and medical center in
london is in an area the world health
organization classifies as having toxic
air pollution that's according to the
london atmospheric emissions inventory
which found despite areas meeting legal
uk air quality limits they still fail
the stricter who guidelines it comes
after the mother of a schoolgirl who
died from asthma linked to dirty air
urged political leaders to tackle air
pollution
and a new study has found extreme
weather events have accounted for
economic losses in europe of just over
400 billion pounds over the past 40
years
a european environment agency briefing
says extreme weather events like storms
heat waves and flooding have also caused
up to 145 000 deaths the briefing aims
to provide more data-based information
about the impact of extreme climate
change hazards on human health
now while renewable energy sources may
be vital to the country's future energy
makeup the current energy crisis shows
us just how reliant we still are on
polluting fossil fuels but one company
has come up with an idea to help
generate a clean source of energy which
doesn't cost the consumer in the long
run the world's first co-op wind turbine
has been erected in wales and will begin
generating energy for its shareholders
in march
investors will receive a discount on
their energy bills for the 25 plus years
the turbine generates wattage
it could be the stepping stone in future
the consumer-owned green energy models
people need to have a way um to protect
themselves against the you know really
really volatile international energy
markets and by owning your own source of
clean stable price um electricity
it can protect you from um
from the price bikes like like we're
seeing at the moment ripple manages a
co-op so we set up a co people um join
the co-op and it's the co-op that owns
the wind farm but but we basically
manage everything
that the whole process for them so they
can just decide how much of the wind
farm they want to own um go on our
website
we take care of everything um from there
heat pumps or solar those are kind of
static and attached to your house so uh
i'm looking to move house in one or two
years those kind of investments wouldn't
quite make sense where they stay with a
property and i'd potentially lose out on
the money that i've invested if i move
house with this wind turbine investment
that discount comes with me we're seeing
you know huge amounts of um new products
going up um offshore i think in the uk
particularly in england it's really
really difficult to get um planning
consent for any new um wind farm at the
moment so that absolutely has to change
because the uk you know onshore wind is
the cheapest source of electricity in
the uk and it's absolutely crazy
that they're um it's so difficult to get
new projects and built um in england we
think it's the future we just want to do
more and more wind farms getting
thousands and thousands of people and
being able to own their own source of
clean power
do stitching coming up on the daily
climate show i'll be joined by lecturer
in international relations at cardiff
university jen allen and head of
analysis at the energy and climate
intelligence unit simon cran mcgreen and
we're going to be discussing what other
options the government might have to
deal with rising energy prices and what
role should there be for some more
imaginative solutions such as community
wind farms
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
lecturer in international relations at
cardiff university jen allen and head of
analysis at the energy and climate
intelligence unit simon crane mcgreen so
a very good evening to you nice to see
you both
so as you've been hearing about all day
we're all going to see a huge rise in
our energy bills in april over 50 for
most people now the chancellor blamed
the uk's reliance on gas geopolitical
tensions and a long winter for rising
prices and has now promised to support
households by providing 200 pounds off
energy bills to be repaid over five
years from next year and a 150 pound
council tax discount for everyone in
bands a to d
so is that enough what else could the
government do so jen what did you make
of the the government steps in the light
of off gems announcement today its
immediate priority was trying to ease
the pain for consumers do you think
that's the right call we do need to ease
the pain in the short term but this is a
perfect storm it's geopolitical tensions
it's high gas prices coupled with a lot
of energy inefficiency so we need a lot
of energy just to heat our homes to a
comfortable standard we need more than
most countries so couple all those
things together and we have big
structural forces and we have people
caught in the middle of it that are just
trying to heat their homes and 200
pounds might help in the fall but it
won't help in the long term if we keep
seeing all of these big structural
problems at play
and simon what did you make of the
response because some people have been
calling for a windfall tax on oil and
gas companies that could then be passed
on in discounts to consumers they were
pointing out shells big profits today
their profits went up to nearly 20
billion dollars for example would you
have welcomed that move or would you
have worried that that would take away
their potential investment into
renewables into greener energy sources
it's always very complicated to try and
work out exactly where the fossil fuel
companies
will put their money i think the
question of windfall tax it is an option
the government can consider but really
it's just a short-term solution again
the systemic problem as as jen was
saying is the fact that we use too much
gas and gas is an international
commodity trade there are markets which
are very volatile and open to
manipulation we saw just yesterday we
were expecting gas flows from russia
into europe and then mysteriously they
stopped so we're still at the mercy of
this manipulation
and so really talking about windfall
taxes or other issues around the fossil
fuel industry is really just very
short-term and the by far the best
solution is to use less gas and move
away from it entirely in the long term
would you agree with that jen and what
do you make of this idea of a windfall
tax i mean the chancellor made it clear
he wanted to shield north sea oil and
gas producers for the sake of both
energy security and job security and to
to allow those companies to continue to
invest in the green transition what do
you make of that stance
i don't think that companies should be
earning record profits off the back of
the poor it's uh
really difficult for them probably to
try to justify record profits while
people are looking at the incredible
increase in gas prices that they'll be
facing
so a windfall tax probably sends a good
message that if they are going to renew
invest in renewables they're going to
have to do it quickly and meaningfully
or
face a windfall tax that then can be
redistributed to the people that need it
most
and some gas prices are
set to stay high for some time aren't
they i mean the conditions aren't going
to change particularly and we are still
reliant on gas aren't we as a kind of
transition fuel if you like until more
renewable energy comes on stream so do
we just have to
accept it that this is the way of the
future that we're going to have higher
energy prices for some time to come
certainly these high gas prices are
going to remain for at least a year
possibly longer um if the wholesale
price does fall again later this year
it'll take a while to come through to
the retail market so customers
households and businesses
and we are already seeing evidence that
renewables are having an impact in
cutting the prices so gas obviously
affects our heating bills when we use it
for heating it also affects our
electricity bills partly because we use
it for some of our generation but partly
because the way our market works the
most expensive technology usually sets
the price for everyone so gas being very
expensive means that everything is very
expensive however some renewables that
have contracts for difference with the
government actually pay back some of the
excess money that's being paid to the
wholesale market so this quarter alone
the expectation is that some of the new
wind farms are going to be paying back a
total of 600 million pounds that will
eventually make its way back to
consumers and as bigger and cheaper and
more efficient wind farms come online in
the coming years
those paybacks will become commonplace
even if the gas price falls again
because those renewables are so cheap
very interesting and i'm glad you talked
about wind farms because we are going to
introduce this idea that the uh we've
talked about the government solution
what about some of the more imaginative
solutions and only we did hear about a
shared ownership of a wind farm
and in bristol local communities are
investing into solar projects in order
to move off grid so simon do you think
an idea like this a kind of shared
ownership of a wind turbine could could
take off and give consumers an
alternative way of getting their bills
down
it certainly is a very beneficial
approach and there are countries
such as denmark and germany where
community energy has been very very
successful
and not only is it a way of people
investing um and getting a return it's
as a way of them getting cheaper energy
from renewables it also really helps to
build a sense of interest and engagement
with a whole energy question and people
tend to be more energy efficient more
interested in insulation to bring their
bills down and just generally more
welcoming of the transition so i think
community energy really does have a very
valuable role potentially
what do you make of this i mean the one
issue is it does require people to put a
lot of money in up front before they get
the benefit and people are suffering
this squeeze on their finances at the
moment so how practical do you think it
could be
it could be that such a community model
like this might be a way to get into the
energy market that wouldn't be possible
otherwise if you think about putting
solar panels on your house that's a big
upfront cost that
we can't afford right now not a lot of
people can
even if you're going to earn that money
back over time so
something like this where you pay a
little bit and then you start to see the
benefit that might be possible for a lot
of people and it might sort of demystify
energy you know like where we wonder
where our food comes from this might
help people kind of understand where
their energy comes from
okay well we must leave it there for
today but jen allen and simon crown
agree and really interesting to get your
views thanks very much indeed
so that's it for today but tomorrow i'll
be joined by economist vicki price and
climate columnist for the independent
donega mccarthy thanks for watching see
you next time
[Music]
you